well it's officially summer now so what
do y'all do for like vacations you go
big or do you chill
well we just got back from the dominican
republic okay so you go big okay
we go big i guess we go big uh but
sometimes we don't go big um
we're usually on a film set somewhere do
you vacation like around your jobs i've
done that too i i try to if we're making
fast usually yeah um
i equate making movies to playing speed
chess
so there's never a down moment
if you're not on set you're working
something out you're working something
out with a scene later or you're working
out some story point or you're
perfecting a stunt that's about to come
up so there's never really i always
fantasize we're going to london to film
fast nine oh my god i'm going to be able
to travel all over europe yeah but when
you when you start making the movie
it's too intense it's too demanding it's
too yeah you have to put everything into
it um like anything in life but i mean
like whenever you finish it see i can't
do it while working either everybody was
asking like how was london like well the
arena was great
like the airport is fabulous i didn't
see much but i always liked if i plan a
vacation with my family i do it like
after i finish work we're not giant
planners oh god you would hate me no
we're not joking
i liked a certain amount of planning we
just go
to the caribbean
um or we'll go you're definite beach
island people there okay
okay no mountains no snow we do um i
have uh
one of my favorite places is upstate new
york and it's um yeah all rural it's
it's actually
there's this hill that fdr used to have
picnics on that we bought and
it's a love that you know that yeah yeah
i love that usually after every fast i'd
always have to go out to the woods with
the bears
shed the character for a month before i
go into something else yeah there is
that process of kind of you can't walk
around with the character your whole
life i feel like yeah that's got to be
kind of overwhelming especially in such
a huge franchise that you're constantly
playing this character
do you is that hard to get lost in well
that's that's an interesting thing like
i said my father was a thespian so it
was very common for us to have
actors from actor's studio and stella
adler all at dinner at my house wow and
recently my father said what none of
those actors ever anticipated
would be the task of playing a character
over two decades how you would evolve
a character over two decades
to make the ninth chapter
as compelling if not more compelling in
the first chapter
[Music]
you